[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
jeux de garçon je suis officiellement
un
poisson
[Musique] bon
sang, je souhaite un garçon de feuille de temps
[Applaudissements]
[Musique] [
Applaudissements] [
Musique] [
Applaudissements] [Musique] [
Musique]
Non
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[Applaudissements] [
Musique] [Musique] [Musique] [
Applaudissements] [Musique] [
Applaudissements]
[Musique]
tu me connais,
ce
sera moins
- hein
[Musique]
as-tu trompé
tu vois  bien que
la scène initiale
[Musique]
vous connaissez
et la
mrs.  Wong
si je vois
[Musique]
[
Musique] [
Musique] [Musique] [Musique
]
bébé [Musique
] [Musique
] [
Musique]
décision simple [Musique] [
[Musique]
ne m'en donne pas un
ne regarde
pas
Donna
ne tombe même pas
beignet nada n'envoie
pas ça par email
[Musique]
Oh Oh
qui est ta famille
ferme-la
juste nous [
Musique]
ne sois pas idiote fille ne fais pas plus de vaisselle sur
le seul  château
banal
tu devrais le zoo
juste une fée
[Musique]
[Applaudissements] [
Musique] [Musique] [Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
Turquie nous avons dit
est-il
[Musique] [
Musique]
Leticia
[Musique]
prends juste une blague
[  Musique]
oui
[Musique]
mon père le savait, c'était les
devoirs musicaux de la porte de chargement
[Musique]
Oh
ce type et
[Musique] [
Musique]
ont fissuré ce chien [
Musique] [
Musique] [Musique] [
Applaudissements]
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique] c'est l'
heure
[Applaudissements]
ton truc,
feu
maintenant
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
tu tues et le dragon
Oh
tu viens juste
[Musique]
tu es défoncé alors oui
Roz
[Musique]
tu es embauché
[Musique  ]
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique] [Musique]
[Applaudissements] [
Musique]
[Applaudissements]
Oh [
Musique]
nouvelles limites sur les supports m'enveloppant
les lits, tous doivent prendre le taxi pour me dire
[Musique]
ne le faites pas
[  Musique]
[Musique]
verre
une
histoire
Oh
[Musique]
Wow al n'en est pas un
okeyday
me poupée [Musique
]
Simona leur achat ou [
Musique] [Musique] [Musique
]
[Musique]
[  Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique] [
Musique]
tu l'aimes plus fille UT poussant le buggy
en effet un promoteur dedans regardait clairement
cette superbe photo de caméra laisse donner à un
frère une performance de laisse-
toi venir T P
Nowak  sur celui de Daisy, il ne parle que d'amour
pour faire connaître les mémoires de Pâques guerre chic
[Musique]
un oui
envisagé
[Musique]
oh mon Dieu nous avons trouvé zéro
mes chaussures ici
pourquoi les bonbons
qu'ils veulent viennent de
me donner
[Musique]
Il me
manque
quelques
dirigeants d'un  gros
[Musique]
connard, c'est toi, est-ce qu'il ou elle est depuis longtemps
le publiciste avec ma baguette magique
Oh
[Musique]
parce que c'est ton école
Tommy Bally regarde
dans les lavages,
Dan était juste des bonbons [
Musique]
donnons-moi juste
whoa
[Musique  ]
mon
il a compté
[Musique]
Père Carmi ils le regardent
il lave le
réalisme ils l'ont lancé pourquoi juste donne-
moi celui-là
donne-moi juste
[Musique]
à
hé hé
[Musique]
Oh mon Dieu,
ils ont positif
ce mouvement alors qu'ils viennent de me donner
[  Musique]
Ceaser est bien,
elle a lié Vitale à vendre
ça aussi,
elle a lié Vitale
ce soir, épelle-le
pour moi, créateur,
Jésus,
ombrage-le, mec, Cassie,
assieds-toi, assieds-toi, assieds-toi,
tu vois ce feu
[Musique]
il faut
sauter, je suppose que tu es
heureux ou  quel mémo mais ta
nourriture au beurre sucré est Julio comme ça moi
[Musique]
soeur partage-moi des fichiers
tu vois jusqu'ici
alors Bagheera
Oh
n'abandonne pas le danger
[Musique]
ha
sido Cheeburger
termine
quinze
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors c'est ordre
mystère pod
flowertchi vieille salive salive
voir ce feu
Spivey
[Musique]
Barbie
RV
[Musique]
chuimu vient de dire
[Musique] [
Applaudissements] [
Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]